move on and talk about medicare and how
do you know if you qualify for it and
more importantly
how do you know which how to choose the
right one we checked in with dr tony
alamo with optum care for a full
breakdown
of how medicare works dr alamo welcome
back
well thank you for having me here this
afternoon yeah it's been a while we
haven't talked about medicare in
months here so let's break down the
basics for people who is eligible for
medicare
very good well that's a great question
and there are several categories so let
me go through them real fast
if you're at least 65 years of age gets
you eligible for medicare advantage
if you're under 65 to have a qualifying
disability that too
can make you eligible for medicare
advantage there's another criteria you
could be any age
if you suffer two disease states for
example
end stage real disease or als that
too can make you eligible if you've
moved from another area and now you live
here in southern nevada
you can go ahead and jump on an mma plan
um
at the end of the day though if your fee
for service medicare
65 and older with none of the things
i've mentioned
well there are enrollment periods and
what are the best steps for
choosing your medicare plan i know you
mentioned medicare medicare advantage
everybody needs to look at their own
situation there's
there's just not one plan for everybody
it's many plans for many people right
so look at look at yourself and see what
doctors and specialists do i need
what medications do i take what other
services do i want
you know you have to make sure that if
you're seeing currently certain pcps
or certain specialists make sure they're
on the plan
if you're already taking certain
medications by all means make sure
they're covered
there's other things too that some
patients may not realize that they need
or want you know dental vision hearing
fitness memberships
transportation services all those things
even though you may not be using them
now
you may want them in the future look at
the plans that offer those
exactly i see you guys say personalize
your choice so that's really important
there's a lot of plans out there so look
at each one
and look again the networks may be
similar they may be different what i
mean by networks
i mean who the doctors on uh what
services are there
look at each one and make the fit for
you
it's it's hard for someone to do this on
their own and that's why we have
independent agents and we also have a a
line which i think you're going to
socialize
where they can call and get advice ask
for help
and what other resources do people have
to get more information there's
always your physician believe it or not
your doctor is a good source
of information because he is
participating on some of these plans
ask him ask your doctor what do you
think would work for me
uh you can ask your staff there's plenty
of independent brokers out there
that can definitely get you a good
informed information
and here at united healthcare and of
course
optum services we have phone lines
just for this but i always go back to
the number one source ask your doctor
ask your doctor you can also go to
medicare.gov right that's easy enough
absolutely if you know how to operate a
computer which i've had to learn how to
do
southwest medical has several locations
across southern nevada call them at
702-242-7119
to speak with an agent or visit
smalv.com for more
in las vegas now we